When the History Channel decided to base a
series around people cutting down trees, none
of us could have imagined the colorful characters
they'd introduce to the world.
The excitement doesn't end when the Ax Men
cameras stop rolling, either.
Here are just a few of the things the show's
producers didn't catch on film.
JImmy Smith’s Illegal Salvage
Back in 2009, S&S Aqua Logging got into some
hot water with the Department of Natural Resources
for illegally salvaging wood from a river.
As sunken logs become an integral part of
a river bed, removing them can cause a lot
of damage the ecosystem.
DNR officers became suspicious of S&S after
seeing them do some shady stuff on an episode
of Ax Men.
So, for future reference, committing a crime
on TV is a really bad idea.
To prevent further harm, DNR officials seized
over two dozen logs from S&S.
Unfortunately for company owner Jimmy Smith,
this wasn't the end of his troubles...
Disability Fraud
In addition to stealing wood, Jimmy Smith
allegedly bilked more than $50,000 in fraudulent
disability benefits.
During the time Smith salvaged the timber
in question, he was also collecting medical
benefits for two claims he filed with the
Department of Labor and Industries, one from
1993 and another from 1996.
According to a surgeon, Smith had complained
of "Impairments" in his "shoulders, neck,
back, or any other portions of the extremities."
In other words, things that would prevent
him from cutting and moving large pieces of
wood and equipment, as he was seen doing on
television.
His trouble with the law didn't last much
longer, though.
After pleading guilty to the fraud allegations
in 2011, Smith passed away in 2012.
Katelyn Sims’ illness
While some loggers have been accused of cashing
in on injuries they don't have, Katelyn Sims
is the exact opposite.
The young logger has battled cystic fibrosis,
a terminal illness, since she was four.
She doesn't let that stop her from felling
and moving trees, however, making some of
her male counterparts look like wimps in the
process.
To fight the disease's effects, Sims undergoes
regular treatments, allowing her to keep active
and continue working, increasing her odds
of survival.
Sims also uses her fame to help spread CF
awareness.
"My name is Katelyn Sims.
I'm a Cystic Fibrosis advocate, and I'm a
student at Sante Fe College."
This is one tough lady.
Death of a logger
Logging is dangerous work, and some of Ax
Men's stars have, sadly, lost their lives
on the job.
Helicopter logger Bart Colantuono died in
2013 while attempting to airlift some lumber
in Oregon.
According to witnesses, a rotor came off his
chopper, which then flipped upside down.
The incident prompted a lengthy investigation.
Mike Pihl’s arrest
Logging seems to attract unusual personalities.
Such is the case with Mike Pihl, owner of
the aptly-named Mike Pihl Logging.
In 2009, Pihl got into an alcohol-induced
fender bender and flipped his Jeep, injuring
three of his kids.
Since the accident occurred on private property,
the police filed no DUI charges, but they
did charge Pihl with felony assault.
Fortunately, Pihl hasn’t been in any trouble
since.
Roger Gunter’s poaching
Master diver Roger Gunter has been caught
six times for hunting without a license.
Before he gained fame on Ax Men, Gunter was
already a well-known Florida monkey fisher.
For the uninitiated, "monkey fishing" refers
to fishing using electricity...
not fishing for actual monkeys.
He was caught six times over a 30-to-40 year
span.
But since then, Gunter has apparently mended
his ways, even befriending the local authorities
with whom he once butted heads.
"It's a really unlikely friendship, considering
Bob spent his career not trying to catch fish,
but trying to catch Roger."
"Well I don't chase him anymore, and he doesn't
run from me."
Shelby Stanga’s arrest
In October 2014, Shelby "Swamp Man" Stanga
was picked up by the police for cutting down
his neighbor's tree.
While that might not sound like a big deal,
remember, it does count as destruction of
private property, vandalism, or both.
Curiously, the cutting took place three years
before the actual arrest.
Apparently, trees have some busy protectors
down there in the bayou.
"As a matter of fact, kids, I'm swamped."
Authenticity questions
Like most reality shows, Ax Men has to deal
with accusations of inauthenticity, many from
people who work within the logging industry.
According to some real-life loggers like veteran
Bill Sword, Ax Men presents an overly dramatic
picture that's pretty far from the truth.
Sword told The Oregonian,
"Those producers drum up a bunch of baloney
to make it dramatic."
"Holy s---!"
"Guys, guys!
Get our stuff!
Get our stuff!"
"Aww f---!"
"Lookout!
Ahhh!"
"Lookout below!"
Hmmm...you be the judge.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you think of Ax Men...